hey let's go Bryce my name is we're
gonna play some more bits each today I
love this game so much is a lot of fun
we have our backs to the Beast we're
gonna defeat those destroy it
Frey Frey Dirk Amoy do they do anything
no how do we kill all of them I don't
know
but I have an idea and it's crazy enough
that he may wear it this is the status
machine I've seen in my life this what
was I thinking now this is a machine I
love it
Ed's friends know get there eventually I
call it the eel of death
I can't build anything decent it makes
me so sad it's this game this is
soul-crushing alright
four people are idiots all right look at
this ha yes oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
calm down look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah this is what I wanted to build
everyone this is why I studied three
years engineering don't worry about it I
know how things work all right
she is complete the Deaf poker yes yes
all right let's try around Princeton
apiece it's way better
rest in peace rest in peace my studies
what what do they do in there I know I
know I'm probably just supposed to have
armor or some stupid [ __ ] but the penis
protection works
where are condom kids all right come
here come here baby
that's right no one [ __ ] heard base to
the Beast attack yeah Oh God Betty are
you okay
[ __ ] what happened
come on man
he doesn't want to fight now when a
[ __ ] come on what an [ __ ] alright
alright we're gonna have to launch quick
and then get the [ __ ] out
yes that's how we do it
[ __ ] basically you're [ __ ]
yourself right now what is going on here
Betsy
calm down back ok so now it's in place
oh [ __ ]
ok Oh God Plan B Plan B this is going to
be the greatest [ __ ] thing you've
ever seen yeah no it goes too far ok how
do I prevent it from going so [ __ ]
far that awkward moment when you miss
the hole ok this tactic seems to be
working some lamb ok spend so much time
on this I can't give up on it now I'll
never give up ok I think I think we
solved the problem res yeah now recipes
recipes recipes
come at me bro there's our bid all right
that's it a beast you're not killing
anyone Bessie
that's a Betsy there bears my pole is
gone [ __ ]
whoa [ __ ] out busy the problem is the
[ __ ] pole you're supposed to be a
weapon of destruction god dammit you're
acting like someone made you with duct
tape I guess I'm the one to blame shut
up alright we're gonna have to change
the inks [ __ ] I'm so pissed right now
okay I just had the greatest idea
[ __ ] given to mankind since Jesus
Christ do you see this [ __ ] do you see
this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you then
this game is stressing me the [ __ ] out
I'm [ __ ] sweating like a [ __ ]
why are you such a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
okay that's how we'll do it
look at this I call it best fit a penis
no balance out fellas hot balance out
balance the [ __ ] out best day I'm just
gonna try I'm so done so done with you
Betsy
eat my dick all right you ready for this
I'm not
what happened we're spun miss the
flamethrower [ __ ] I forgot all right eat
my dick good job
here we go cha-cha-cha Don OH
back database that did not go as planned
in it you [ __ ] idiot
okay so if if we can make this bestie
flameproof this is a great idea
if this doesn't work look at it it's
[ __ ] flawless okay new plan
all right that worked great
Betsy that beast
never go
[ __ ] I missed [ __ ] I missed ah [ __ ]
[ __ ] hell
at this [ __ ] again
sweet head Oh God Bessie's not doing too
well I'm please please please I gotta
fire everything at once alright you
ready here we go
thank me sir
ah it crashed no this is not the time
for crashing please please yes I okay it
saved no it didn't save that's machine
you failed me
this is not are you alright then
this is continually getting there that's
Paris now I want you to do it really
alright think we have enough [ __ ]
cannons now maybe it's a lot faster
enough no why
this one is wrecking housing surprise
[ __ ]
[ __ ] this is Betsy 2.0 baby you can't
[ __ ] with this girl you know you can't
[ __ ] we did all eat
all right
oh my god I'm [ __ ] one-shotting these
[ __ ] like it's [ __ ] MLG alright
now I'm gonna shoot everything at once
at its target
going to be like [ __ ] Orchestra
get rekt
Bessie's sort of silly tag no problem
don't crash I swear to God
oh okay that said that's all the maths
for now oh man I was really enjoying
myself and [ __ ] well I guess we'll have
to end it there
Thank You boys for watching let me know
if you want more when there's time for
more hit click here for more when there
is time for more don't be a war unless
you're a born your snoring Madore stay
awesome I guess right Celebes passerbys
they see the Beast see everybody face
see the Beast this seat please
spinning block of flame throw damn it